Uh, good morning. Um,
now the move to our last alter
in discourse to Emile Durkheim,
uh, that rd Ali to Durkheim's. Uh,
we have seen certainly to Marxists and to,
uh,
uh, Weber's, uh, that I'd also
two faces of Emil Dirk time.
Uh, to put it bluntly, uh,
the young Durkheim,
uh,
has been a functionalist and the
positivist and then late in his life,
he has his epistemological churn.
He became a cultural analyst.
Well,
it's not quite true because you know,
each author is more complex and there are
already elements of his cultural is in
the early Varick,
but there was certainly a
dramatic change in the Va,
how Durkheim conceived the,
um,
but what the job of social sciences
later in his life in his book,
uh,
the alimentary forms of religious life,
I think it had a lot to do
also with his personal life.
And if you're talking about
this, um, he was, uh, uh,
brought up here and I'd have been a core
family and it was supposed to become a
rabbi and then he revolted
against the parental household.
Um, much like Nicha did, uh,
turned probably in 28 days,
but certainly not an
active believer in Judaism.
And later in his life.
Um, he became again,
interested in religion and
not only a philosophically,
but also existentially
interested in religion.
Um, well in the course, uh, we have
only four lectures on Durkheim,
so I leave a Durkheim,
the culturalist out and Vivio
doing a very only on the,
a earlier very, um, uh,
the division of Labor.
Uh,
the wonderful book suicide and as
somewhat difficult book the rules of
sociological mattered. Uh, um,
and I,
uh,
I just leave the elementary
form of religious life.
I don't have time to fit
this into a Durer came,
had a extra ordinary impact on the,
uh,
American social science.
Um,
initially it was particularly
the younger Durkheim.
The functional is Durkheim who
had such an extra ordinary impact.
Um, uh, unlike, uh, uh,
vapor or Marx whose impact was brewed.
And the fact that history and economics
and political science Durkheim impact
was much more focused on the sociology.
So in the scores,
the only author who properly
speaking is a sociologist,
is Emil Durkheim.
All the others you discussed?
Um,
uh,
we're not really identified themselves
as sociologists later in his life.
He did did, uh, but,
uh, not, uh, uh, uh, uh,
uh, on the whole Emile Durkheim, uh, uh,
identified himself and his
project as a sociology.
Uh, it, of course has lots of food,
lots to do that these disciplinary
boundaries between economics,
political science and sociology became
much more sharp redrawn by the end of 19
and early 20th century.
Um,
and the sociology as an
academic discipline was
really established by the late
19th century.
So this is Emile Durkheim
born in 1858 and died in 1917.
Just very briefly about his life.
He was born in a small down Epi now in
France because I said he's a father,
was a rabbi and the,
uh,
he was expected to become
at home by himself. Uh,
in 79, he was admitted to
the Ecole Normale superieure,
which is one of these very
elite schools, MIT, uh,
uh, version in France. Um, and, uh,
uh,
by the time he went to a university,
you called northern mass
per year is a university.
Um, uh, he lost his religious beliefs.
Um, uh, he was, uh, uh,
for some time a professor at
the University of Bordeaux. Uh,
then he became politically
active in the 1940s,
um, especially in the so
called Dreyfus affair.
And Ivo just briefly mentioned
what that was, uh, uh,
than 1902.
He became professor at the
University of batteries,
which is not quite as distinguished
as a core Nora mastery per year.
Uh,
uh,
he's sign avast killed the end of war
and shortly after this he died in Paris.
So this is Alfred Dreyfus.
This is a very important event in French
and in many ways in European history.
What was the drive was to have
fear? You're probably, or no,
in 1894 Dreyfus who was a, uh, Jewish,
uh, it was, uh,
a falsely accused to be a
German spy and it was, uh,
uh, imprisoned, uh, that
was, uh, obviously, um,
an antisemitic trial.
And these mobilized,
the French intellectuals are not only
French intellectuals, uh, but uh, uh,
uh, French intellectuals
in particular, um,
Emile Zola,
uh,
whom some of you may have rather a the
leading French writer of this ebook rule,
an important article
which appeared in the, uh,
French leading French daily newspaper.
Yakuza I accuse the French should
this study of being anti Semitic.
Now Derek came joy into other
prominent intellectuals to protest,
to trial. It took them a long time,
but eventually they were successful.
Dreyfus was eventually exonerated of
all charges and amid the night of the
Legion of honor. So it was,
uh, a happy ending, uh,
French antisemitism,
a photo via then it came
back with van Jams, um,
during the occupation
Nazi occupation franchise,
not as innocent about antisemitism
as you may want to believe it.
Uh, uh, many of you are
collaborating with the Nazis.
Well about the Verruca in 93,
he wrote a dissertation and which it
probably is still his most influential
book, the Division of Labor in
society. And today's lecture,
if you will be focused on this,
uh,
95 feet first followed by the rules
of sociological and mattered, uh,
which is, uh, his most
positivistic statement.
The division of Labor is his
most functionalist work. Um,
and then, uh, in 97, he had all suicide.
A suicide is a very important
book because it's three early,
the first piece of rigorous
empirical social science,
which takes a very unusual,
very rare phenomenon like suicide and,
uh,
crunches numbers extremely carefully to
test where that he can identify social
determinants of such a real
phenomenon. Uh, fortunately, uh,
even in countries where
many people commit suicide,
like side is still area for
an [inaudible]. Uh, it's, uh,
but he managed to come up with
a very provocative theory,
but he, um, uh, uh,
demonstrated it very
careful empirical analysis.
Maybe we'll be looking at the two
parts of the division of Labor. Um,
today we will be looking at, uh, uh,
the major arguments of
division of labor. Um, um, um,
and then, uh, also Vivia
look at, uh, uh, uh,
uh, Thursday on his theory of Anime, uh,
which is a central piece of the
book, division of Labor. Um, uh,
but, uh, uh, uh, I kind
of a bite of a, um, uh,
analysis. Um, uh, uh, uh,
and as I said in 1915,
he wrote this book,
the elementary forms of religious life,
which is a major break
in his work. Uh, uh,
uh,
and the shorts,
his renewed interest in the
spiritual and the metaphysical.
Okay. Uh, just, uh, very briefly
what is in the box. As I said,
the division of Labor
was his phd dissertation,
but on like money, uh, um, uh,
scholars who's a only go the book is
that dissertation and Durkheim full audit
up for Viet a number of
good other books. Um, uh,
many festivals,
I'd actually one book people,
or at least they should have been because
there are only good book for us that
is sufficient and what they publish
later only published because publish or
perish, right? To get tenure.
That's why they probably published
too many books. Um, anyway, um,
he was inspired by Montesquieu.
Um, uh, they all do it.
Academies, Very French, uh,
and his roots are deeply in,
won't askew and to some
extent in Jerusalem. Uh,
he admired Russo as val, but
Montesquieu is really, uh,
the, uh, major, um, inspiration
behind him. And, uh,
well what he does, he uses law as
a measure of social development,
uh, uh, much life.
Montesquieu did sort of a, um,
uh, um, uh, and, uh,
uh, he explains, uh, uh,
by using the law or the legal
system, um, uh, uh, how, um,
the division of labor of war,
of the,
what were the stages of the development
of division of Labor? There are,
um, uh, just a very brief
for contrast, right?
Maurice was interested in
economic conflict, right?
In struggle at and, uh, um, uh,
scares economic resources.
The Zebra was interested in
struggle for power. I Sovos nature,
they're kind of was interested
in social solidarity. Um,
uh,
Mark's and vapor are conflict theorists.
They tried to explain about
breaks up society. Um,
Durkheim is a tiered is the of each
just to understand what holds society
together but brings us together.
Arisal Saturday is not falling apart.
Uh,
right now,
uh,
in the book he makes a crucial distinction
between two types of solidarity,
mechanical and organic
solidarity. Um, and,
uh, uh, I've, you'll speak
about this at great lengths.
This is an other attempt to develop a
type pathology of evolution of societies.
You are already familiar with
Mark's more soft production, right?
The evolution from slavery
to feudalism to capitalism.
You're all familiar with Max Faber,
traditional authority and
legal rational authority. Now,
direct camps alternative is
mechanical and organic solidarity,
right?
But a vapor called traditional authority
is kind of mechanical solidarity for
Durkheim or Marx called
pre capital is formations,
is mechanical solidarity,
organic solidarity.
Describe legal rational authority
or modernity or capitalism.
Uh,
uh,
he also identified the pedal and
Dzhokhar pedological forms of division of
labor.
And this is what he called anime.
And his idea of anime is a kind of
similar or analogous distinction.
What was,
what was alienation in marks and what
it was this enchantment in the vapor,
uh, a door that are very
important differences as well.
And I will be talking about this
tourists today now on suicide.
As I said,
this is the one of the first very
rigorous empirical studies of a social
phenomenon.
A phenomenon we think is not quite social.
They think it is really an individual
decision whether you take your life or not
about Durkheim actually was capable to
show that even in these very private
action when you take your life
that are social determinance,
who is committing suicide or not,
and he's making a distinction
between different types of suicide.
Annemieke,
altruistic,
egoistic and fatalistic Vance and
ivy would be talking about this,
uh,
after you returned from Thanksgiving
spray now about the methodology,
he was a methodological collectivists,
much like Montesquieu or Shaw and
very much online cops lock or mills.
You know, Mark's being kind of halfway
between methodological individualism and
collectivism as a teary stuff,
revolutionary consciousness.
He evolves at evolution as a
methodology called call activists.
Maybe you'll see a deer camps notion of
collective conscience is not all that
different from Weber's. Uh, Mark's
idea of class consciousness,
which is not the sum total right of the
individual consciousness are very curse.
Uh, uh, but, uh,
Mark's in his theory of exploitation as
you have read his stacks reach almost
like Adam Smith or John Stuart Mill,
right?
It's a self interest
international individuals from
which he explains the nature
of exploitation. Arielle, it's much
more difficult to figure it out,
but how VBA Fitzy cause
we scatter goodies.
I think he's also [inaudible] between
collectivism and individualism later in
his life is becoming more of a
methodological individualism.
But Dirk kind of consistency in Durkheim,
is that from Dave Ron,
he's a methodological collectivist and
remains I the logic God called activist.
But at the same time he believed
in the existence of social facts.
Um,
and the social facts on the other hand
can be observed which rigorous and
[inaudible] and methodology.
And this is what makes him a in,
in a v a positivist. So this is a, uh,
just a brief introduction to a who the
orchard is an now let me move over to the
division of Labor. Um, and uh,
yeah,
all my computer getting slower
as the semester is progressing.
So it's probably time for the semester
to end because my laptop though it is
new, it's still, uh,
there'll become unbearably slow
by the end of the semester. Okay.
So this is Emil Durkheim and the
division of Labor in society.
So how does a Durkheim proceed?
Um,
in the Varick and a,
uh,
today's presentation will focus,
on the question. Why do a kind
of begins the analysis, uh, uh,
by taking the law as a,
the point of departure.
Um, uh, and uh, uh, uh, uh,
Dan, uh, Viveo, uh,
proceed how he makes the
distinction between organic and,
uh, um, uh, um, uh, mechanical solidarity.
Um, uh, so, uh,
the question actually is what I
methodological called activist, uh, uh,
uh, uh, that you need to find the, um,
some of collective expression,
uh,
in order to study society
and not individuals.
And a march, like Montesquieu, um,
he be beliefs that the law is
such a collective phenomenon,
a law,
which again,
be studied and established the,
to studying individual views
or individual opinions. Right.
Uh, it's a, uh, Bart's off,
uh, about, uh, you know, uh,
during camps during the analogy
is the collective conscience,
um, nerve, which is, uh, uh, at
Bhava individual consciousnesses. Ah,
okay. So that's, um, uh, uh, uh, what,
what are the most important, uh, issues,
uh, um, in, in the very few,
as far as we discuss it today,
uh, val, he is interested in,
in solidarity. Um, as
I pointed out, uh, uh,
uh, um, uh, the, our, uh, his,
his real question is what
holds society together?
The are so different and
society short fall apart.
And it is a writing in the late 19th,
early 20th century.
This is the time of industrialization
of urbanization. People are,
this launched from that,
um,
the traditional communities from
the traditional villages, uh,
Gustave from Besant agriculture and
move into urban industrial employment.
Um, and the question is, um, a
veal society breakdown, social VR,
social order breakdown. Um, if, uh,
the traditional order does not keep us
together and this is what he tries to
figure it out,
what in a modern,
urban and industrial society cannot
keep us together and he tries to find a
Saudi daddy did and, uh, uh, well, uh,
uh, uh, uh, what creates
is a solidarity, uh,
is called lefty for
consciousness. Uh, um, uh,
the fundamental idea about indirect
came about collective consciousness.
Um,
as I said,
it is a analogous to the
notion of the genital veal,
um, uh, in the, uh, uh,
a little sore or, uh,
the notion of class consciousness,
sir, uh, in Mark's, uh, uh,
so therefore it is not the sum
total of individual consciousnesses,
uh, but, uh, something, uh,
uh, of, uh, shared norms,
beliefs and values which exist prior
and individual is being born prior,
uh,
society actually existed,
which is passed on from one
generation to the other. Right.
And, uh, uh, therefore he tries to show,
right these collective consciousnesses
of which persist over time.
Um, and, uh, of course, the most obvious,
most rigorous way to go about this,
to look at law because that's
exactly what the law is,
right?
The law is changing over time,
but usually, uh, the change is very,
very slow and reaches
over several generations.
Uh, so, uh, ever before,
somebody who is a French social
scientists, you know, and run the Unifi,
we already talked about this. Uh, uh, uh,
the French are very methodological
collectivists the Anglo Saxon send to be
methodological individualist.
Um, and the French online,
the German, um, are very scientific.
The are very much scientists. Um, uh,
delivered our CRT thick,
uh,
in German does not exist.
Uh, the German say, um, uh,
API, this and shaft La
vison shaft means, uh,
um, uh, uh, vison is
knowledge, uh, uh, um,
uh,
science in German is constituted
by all sorts of knowledge, right?
It's a much broader notion,
right?
In French or in English bit
sciencey really mean rigorous
science of the natural
science.
Stipes.
Now that's Derrick hand did not go as
far as saying it is natural science,
but certainly he was very scientific
in insistence of rigorous analysis.
Uh, our firm objective data,
right? That's what, uh, uh, uh,
why the Germans, you
know, Vincent Schaffler,
all those who study ideas, uh, uh,
Bisson shufflers it's a much,
much,
much broader notion of natural scientists
are also vison shufflers but people
who study humanities and history of ideas.
I'd also vison Shufflers,
uh,
people who are an expert on co ops and
spend their life writing on hops is a
vison shuffler right?
In German we can hardly see
somebody who does right.
History of ideas to be a scientist,
right? It's uh, uh, uh, the,
we call it, you know, humanities. Um,
it talks about social sciences, uh, uh,
with a lot of anxiety and real
scientist ask cross social science.
What do you mean? What is science
about what you are doing? Well,
those of you who take economics,
they make sure it looks like silence
because you have all the equations on the
blackboard. So therefore, you
know, a scientist can relax,
but you,
if you are listening to my lectures and
not a single equation on the blackboard,
you probably have doubt that this is
the reality. Social Science. Anyway,
he was a CRT faker in chance of being
very rigorous and his analysis sort of
artist collective consciousness.
I give, uh, here, uh, um,
uh, a, um, a citation for you,
right? Uh, um, uh, if there's, uh,
a totality of beliefs and sentiments of
each are common to the average member of
society,
right?
But which has a life of its own.
All right.
Um,
uh,
that's what he calls a
collective consciousness.
So this is, uh, uh,
different from the consciousness
is of the individuals and door.
You know, he, he's a, he's
a scientist, uh, right?
Is she on traffic?
And it is,
has to be realized in
individuals. So therefore, I mean,
Durkheim, I will not
necessarily be opposed, uh, uh,
to carry out even survey research and
ask individuals about the custom sort of
values and the sort of aggregate this
up and try to find those patterns,
especially overtriage
diamond across nation.
That's not really what he did,
but I think he would be open
for these kind of half research,
which of course made him so influential
in early American sociology in the
1930s, forties and 50s. Because, uh, um,
American sociology has been very
positive and very embedded car.
Now,
uh,
but the most obvious example of
collective conscience is, uh,
the law, probably also
the language. Well, uh,
there are differences,
uh,
in law and the three modern
and modern societies.
Now we are getting into,
he's building the argument opt to make
the distinction between organic and,
uh, um, uh, uh, mechanical,
mechanical and organic solidarity.
Um, and, uh, uh, left me just,
uh, uh, Gore through of this, uh,
uh,
ops,
too far. Okay. Um, so, uh,
in the argument is done in,
in pre modern societies,
uh, uh, the,
the law of each existed is Brian
Maternity or repressive or penal law.
Um, uh, val that, uh, you
know, that is, uh, uh,
the purpose of Bunich Mandt is to punish
evil behavior and we tend to agree what
is eve? Your behavior is, uh, um,
and punishments. So therefore,
also tends to be harsh, uh,
to, uh, prevent, uh, uh,
further, um, uh, aggressive
behavior. Um, uh, uh, by,
uh, individuals, uh, uh, uh, sued.
This is, uh, the legal system
of pre modern societies.
Well,
I will give you a couple of
citations and I won't read them.
Uh, I will put them on the
intranet and you can see the, uh,
to at your leisure. It
kind of elaborates, uh, on,
on the points I made.
Um, uh, uh, uh,
okay. Uh, but in modern society, uh,
the legal system is very different.
Uh,
the legal system is based on contract.
The essence of modern
legal system is contract.
There's not that we do not
have a pin or cold, right?
The penal code survives.
But what is of a novel is a,
uh, a contractual, uh, law, um,
which is rest of the [inaudible] river,
which is not about punishing EDL,
but simply restitute the damage.
Somebody by baking a contract costs
to the other contracting partner.
Right.
And he said that this is a new
type of law which emerges, uh, uh,
via modernity. Uh, Marshall
will say, uh, it is, uh, uh,
a new legal system,
uh, which emerges a of,
we had to be capitalism
or, uh, um, and, uh,
Vaibhav you'll say this is the
essence of Liga rational authority.
Uh,
uh,
um,
bell. Uh, Oh, why does he study law?
I don't want to elaborate on
this too longer. Uh, that's,
uh, obvious that, uh,
the legal system is the single
best measure of what he,
he tries to get at collective conscience,
which can be the most objectively,
right,
that our law books and
legal practices and, uh, uh,
minutes of, uh, uh, recordings,
how the courts operated and how
low was made and implemented,
which can be studied with great level of,
uh,
rigor. Um, uh, uh, for instance,
it's very easy to study whether
indeed contractual law, um,
is a new form of law are you can go
back to legal history and to establish
exactly then contractual law and merged.
This was actually also very
much undermined, uh, for, uh,
the younger Viber.
Uh,
then he was also looking at basically
the emergence of contractual law.
You can lead to medieval
Italy, um, in, uh, his, uh, uh,
phd for the law degree. Uh, uh, uh,
I think I already made this point.
What is interesting that uh,
Durkheim and labor sort of
ignored each other? Um, uh,
I don't think they ever cited each other.
I don't recall ever seen
a citation to one another.
They were working on the same area.
Of course it was,
the speed did speak most of the languages.
And they were of course aware
that the other giant exists.
They were probably in many ways to close,
um,
too much in competition with
each other to cite each other.
I mentioned already that Durkheim
did review Marianna Weber's book,
but never any of Weber's book,
though Mariana was writing,
write about marriage or a lot of marriage
law of which was a marginal interest
to Durkheim and they've ever
was rotting on religion.
This was so central for their clients
into us and never had their last,
they've kind of
ignored each other.
Now about the two types of solidarity,
uh,
well, uh, mechanical solidarity, uh, it's
real hard to remember the distinction.
One would think organic
solidarity must be old, right?
And mechanical must be
modern. The machines. Now,
the opposite is true.
I,
I kept making these mistakes for the first
two or three years when I was leading
Durkheim some 45 years ago.
Uh,
uh, uh, mechanical or sorry,
Daddy. The, the is, uh, uh, uh,
which describes a pre,
pre modern societies. Um,
and uh, this is a solidarity which
based on the similarities, uh,
uh, of, uh, uh, uh, of,
of, of, of the parts, uh,
um, well this is why
you can have a, um, uh,
a penal law because a penal law does not
make a distinction between contractual
partners.
Uh,
it assumes the sameness
of the group as such, uh,
uh, and uh, uh, mechanical solidarity,
right? Uh, is, uh, as I said,
it's primarily based that we are the,
the seat CRC have similar,
uh, in, in the globe organic solidarity.
A Savill Durkheim argue is one which
is based on differences in society.
A higher level of division of Labor in
society produces organic solidarity,
organic.
He man sits as a kind of
biological analogy and modern
societies like the human
body,
right?
There are functional differences
between the human organs.
That's why these organic solidarity,
right?
The heart performs a different
function than the longer,
but the long could not live
the south of the heart, right?
This is why this is organic.
Saudi, Saudi, Daddy,
the society operates more
like an organism or um,
in the earlier times society was more
operating like a machine where you
actually a party staking out mechanically.
It doesn't matter all that much.
Right? Is a simple machine. Uh,
I mean, so that's a, that's the
fundamental distinction by the way,
also for Durkheim. Um, uh, and
this is also in the Texter,
but you are eating, there's distinction
between mechanical and organic.
Solidarity is,
uh,
developed in order to
describe a societies as such,
but much like,
uh,
the bursts notion of traditional
authority and Legal National Authority,
uh, he is also using this
to understand the, um, uh,
uh, uh, so sad.
The social solidarity
is in contemporary life.
So mechanical solidarity
does exist in the,
uh,
in contemporary society as well.
And he makes, you know, these
reference to finding it. Um,
um,
a marital partner,
the one to day two, it,
uh, and who the, uh, uh,
considered to marry,
uh, um, occasionally Vr,
uh, uh, we tried to find somebody
who is more similar than we are.
Um, and people voc. Well,
uh, you look like a,
if you are heterosexual, I
brothers and sisters, uh,
or if you are a gay, then you look
like brothers or like sisters,
right? You look seen, you, you look,
look similar and that can be right.
A consideration for elastic partnership.
I'm trying to find somebody who
likes the same stuff. What I like,
who is like me, right? But it can
be the opposite as well, right?
You may be looking for that person.
You know,
you may follow the logic of
organic solidarity, right? Uh,
you may be looking for a person who
will compliment you. All right? Uh,
I'm bad in keeping the books. Uh, uh,
and therefore, uh, what I'm
trying to look for a rod,
if somebody who view balanced
the checkbook, right? Um, uh,
so occasionally looking for a partner,
we are looking for somebody
who will compliment us.
Now that describes a right modern society
with a higher level of division of
Labor, division of labor, he says,
can bring us together, um, uh, March,
like,
uh,
the body of the organism that we are
performing different functions in society.
We compliment each other.
They need each other on the basis
of our differences rather than our
similarities. Um, uh, and the, in fact,
the contractual law expresses the spirit,
the AF organic solidarity as such.
Well,
uh, Durkheim veal, uh,
show us that there is a, in fact, uh,
a lot of trouble in the transition
from Oregon from mechanical to organic
solidarity,
and this is what he will call anime,
uh, in the transition from
mechanical to organic Saudi Daddy,
the moving from a traditional
society through our modern society,
our value system breaks down.
We find ourself in the
situation of anime about,
this is a topic I've, you'll be
talking about, uh, uh, jurors there.
Thank you very much.